[موسيقى] أثناء
تجولك في مخيم للاجئين
ترى صفوفًا وصفوفًا من الخيام ، فإن الصدمة
التي عانى منها هؤلاء الأشخاص كانت
شديدة جدًا وتستهلك الحياة ، لذا فأنا
أحضر الرقص إلى مخيم اللاجئين هذا
كأداة علاجية
[موسيقى]
هذا المخيم هو  مليئة باللاجئين
الذين اضطروا إلى الفرار من ديارهم بسبب
داعش ، لقد أخذ هذا النزوح
للتو كل شيء بما في ذلك إرادتهم
حتى المحاولة بسبب اليأس
الذي يأتي من كوني لاجئًا
، فأنا أدرس الرقص في
جامعة بلهافن ، لكنني دائمًا
مهتمة حقًا بكيفية إخراج الرقص
من المسرح وذلك عندما بدأت حقًا
في رؤية نطاق أكبر مع الرقص
وأنه ربما يمكن استخدامه
لشيء أكثر من مجرد نفسي
عندما أتيحت لي هذه
الفرصة للتطوع في المركز  مدرس رقص
لم أتمكن حقًا من مقاومة
رغبة هؤلاء الأطفال في التحرك رائع جدًا لدرجة
أنهم أخذوا الفصل هناك
وكان الضحك والابتسامات على الفور
بغض النظر عن حواجز اللغة التي نتعامل معها  استمتع
بالحركة والكثير من التأشير
والسهام والاتجاهات ونتواصل
مع رقصة أجسادنا ، فهذه
السفينة المدهشة حقًا يمكن أن يحدث الشفاء من أجلها
لأنها تنطوي على
جسدية وتواصل مع نفسك
في جسمك وهذا نوع من
القطع المفقودة هناك  الكثير من التركيز على
عقلك وأفكارك وعواطفك
، ثم في بعض الأحيان يتم إهمال الجسد
أحيانًا نسمي اللاجئين
كلاجئين وهذا كل ما هم عليه ولكن
لديهم نفس الاحتياجات التي يجب
أن نكون مبدعين وأن نتحرك فيها.
وللتنفس والتفاعل مع
إنسانيتهم ، أعتقد أن وجود منفذ إبداعي دا
ل المخيم ضروري جدًا لأ
ه لا يلبي فقط تلك ال
حتياجات من الطعام والمأوى ولكن أيضًا يل
ي تلك الحاجة لهم كبشر أو